des actions et du concret pour respecter
la nouvelle priorité de l'exécutif
vacciner l'ensemble des enseignants
voilà ce que réclament les syndicats
sauf que le flou demeure suite aux
récentes déclarations de certains
membres du gouvernement aux libéraux et
jean michel blanquer ont du mal à
accorder leurs violons
le ministre de la santé avait clairement
affiché sa volonté de vacciner la
totalité à des enseignants au lendemain
à des annonces des manuels macron avant
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
tempère et parle d'un ciblage progressif
au sein du corps enseignant
s'agissant des professeurs notre
objectif c'est que ce soit dans le
courant du mois d'avril selon des règles
de priorité que nous travaillons
actuellement notamment ça commencera par
ceux qui s'occupent des enfants en
situation de handicap
on continuera normalement avec ceux qui
s'occupent des enfants de maternelle et
puis ensuite ce sera un raisonnement
parages tout ce travail se fait
actuellement avec les autorités de santé
avec ses projections les enseignants
pourront espérer être vaccinés à la mi
juin un manque de clarté qui agacent les
syndicats pointent du doigt encore une
fois un manque d'anticipation de la part
du gouvernement pour ouvrir sereinement
les écoles il faudrait vacciner
massivement les personnels et les
professeurs par ailleurs les chiffres
prouvent que les variants du corona des
russes ont changé la donne et que les
écoles sont devenus de véritables lieux
à risque de contamination élevé élèves
professeurs et personnels confondus les
tests positifs aux copies 19 se sont
multipliées ces dernières semaines à
d'où l'inquiétude d'une ouverture trop
précoce des écoles nous ce qu'on demande
c'est pas de passer avant des personnes
qui seraient vulnérables
c'est d'avoir une politique vaccinale où
on dise clairement quand est-ce qu'on
vaccine les uns et les autres
quand est-ce qu'on peut du coup avoir
une
une réouverture sécuriser des
établissements scolaires et des écoles
et qu'on puisse du coup dire on protège
les personnels parce qu'on les faire
revenir au contact des élèves des
usagers etc
donc c'est une volonté d'avoir une
visibilité sur ce qui va être fait et
pour l'instant on ne l'a pas on a une
forme de déni des réalités et du coup un
manque d'anticipation
on découvre les sujets au dernier moment
un déni de réalité qui se traduit par un
retard certain sur d'autres pays
européens selon une étude de le céder en
mars 2021 dans 19 pays sur 30
les enseignants sont prioritaires pour
la vaccination l'espoir affiché par
emmanuel macron reste utopique
même en prenant compte les nouvelles
livraisons de vaccins mi avril la france
compte 1,2 million d'enseignants et
d'agents de l'éducation nationale une
petite partie a déjà pu bénéficier du
vaccin car allah répondaient aux
critères des règles communes mais le
défi logistique reste immense en
ajoutant à l'ouverture de la vaccination
aux personnes de plus de 60 ans à la
mi-avril sans compter l'ouverture de la
campagne aux forces de l'ordre également
prévue à la fin du mois la bataille
risque d'être très longue pour les
enseignants